hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today
mention a question from one of my
readers Egypt who wrote in saying thank
you for all the informative videos I
have a question
crowd we have a crowdfunding campaign to
raise funds for new invention an idea go
go with it we have great response and
sharing people are not donating Kiva
give us some advice are this our first
campaign and might be doing something
wrong did an email blast for one after
the campaign launched post on various
blog LinkedIn Twitter Facebook contact
the friends friend will take part of the
campaign thanks an event so let's see
what we can do so I'm loading up the
page here Egypt typically with these
things you can have a couple of issues
with either your your product or your
messaging is not great and so it is a
healing cap medical wig you know I don't
know too much about the conditions here
chemo burns alopecia to know you know
that's a huge demand or not but either
your messaging your product isn't great
or you have the wrong people come into
your page or not enough people are
coming to your page or some kind of
combination of it so you've got 171
dollars raised out of $150,000 goal with
only seven days left so it's gonna be I
mean tight to get that that finished
looking through let's see what we got
now you have a lot of Facebook likes a
lot of tweets happening here interesting
that there's so many with only $171
contributed I'd start to think that
maybe some of these were bought you know
500 or something like that
you don't want to fake your social media
too much cuz it can cause a lot of
skepticism looking at the video here we
can also check it out if we go watch on
YouTube so we've got 55,000 people who
viewed it 621 thumbs up snow thumbs down
no comments so again that's screaming
that you know these are probably
purchased views or purchased thumbs ups
because usually with the video with that
many views and thumbs ups you'd have
somebody leaving a comment at least on
it so again you know just people who who
are you know faking or social media to
boost our numbers okay and sometimes you
know cause a lot of people to question
whether they should you know be a part
of this company or not so just something
to think about in terms of building the
awareness for this really two most of
the projects that go up on idea Google
or Kickstarter don't end up getting
funded and it's the ones that start
doing well that then make it to the home
page and get the exposure and so before
idea Google's gonna give you any kind of
traction on this and give you the
exposure you have to do a lot of the
groundwork yourself just putting it up
isn't gonna do it and I know you said
you've done a lot of different types of
work that may be driven traffic but it's
probably not the right people who are
coming you know you don't just want
numbers you want qualified people who
are interested in this so what I would
do is try to build up my own list prior
to it and think about three strategies
one guest blogging so you could guest
blog either about the process of
starting something up an idea Google but
but more promising would be target
anybody who has a popular blog in this
kind of field so somebody who writes
about wigs or you know any of those
conditions if you could have a guest
post on there that that then also
promotes your idea google campaign
you're gonna be driving fewer people but
but much more targeted people to the
page number one guest blogging number
two PR and media reach out to you can
look at national media campaigns but
more more likely you get some traction
with the smaller media outlets people
who do talk about these kinds of issues
and let them know you exist let them
know the campaign is here be a resource
with them write a press release
offer the right stories for them as much
as you can to get some media to drive
traffic to this page and get some orders
would be a fantastic idea and the third
is reach out to connectors and
influencers so people who
have a blood blog but tweet a lot about
it or are very active on Google+ or
Facebook or YouTube get them to know
about it get them to partner up and help
help expose it to their audience as well
because to have only $171 here again one
of the problems is either either you
have tons of people coming into this
page but the product and the messaging
are just not great you know people don't
want what you have
now I'm that's probably not what's
happening it's probably more you have
the wrong people coming and not enough
people coming so the people are coming
or either bought from places like Fiverr
or you know the spam doubt and they hit
the webpage but they're not qualified
people who are your potential buyers so
to make any these campaigns go sometimes
it just it's lucky and they and they hit
but usually you have to do a lot of
groundwork on on your own to get up to a
certain dollar amount and then the
website like idea google will help
promote you and get you on the homepage
and give even more exposure so you need
to think about ways that you can already
sell five ten fifteen twenty thousand
dollars of this stuff on your own
through your own connections and through
your own exposure of guest blogging PR
media reaching out to connectors and
influencers because idea gold was not
going to want to put on their homepage
something that only is raised $171 if
they see that there's already been some
momentum then they're going to help you
take that to the next level so hopefully
that helped for those of you watching if
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below and if you have a
question about your own campaign or your
own website I'd love to be able to try
to help you if you want leave it in the
comments section I always read those and
try to respond to everybody so thank you
and I'll see you on the next episode